I'm really proud of v ramaswami v has
just unlocked a new political
specifically Republican achievement he
has been compared to a Nazi on CNN that
guy is dangerous that's dangerous um
when those people were saying Jews will
not replace us Jews will not replace us
that slogan sits on top of a very sick
and twisted view that if you bring
enough people of color here we are so
deficient we are so stupid we are so
unwanted that we will be zombies to fill
out the the ranks for some democratic
party agenda that Jewish people are
manipulating and driving forward that
leads to violence uh that puts at risk
Jewish people that puts at risk people
of color it is wrong and the smug
condescending way that he just spew this
poison out is very very dangerous
because he won't stop Trump but he's
going to outlive Trump by about 50 years
and you're watching the rise of an
American demagogue that is a very very
despicable person and I I'm literally I
I was I was shaking listening to him
talk because a lot of people don't know
that is one step away from Nazi
propaganda coming out of his mouth
that's what that's it that's what he was
doing if you listened really carefully
not if you listened to the words that V
said which were totally unobjectionable
but if you listen really carefully to
like the dog whistle pitches in between
all the notes and the words then what he
actually said sounded a lot like
is no I don't think so I don't did you
hear any Nazi propaganda from V
ramaswami what V said
was there's a program of mass migration
coming into this country that the libs
want because it displaces Americans and
it gives them an advantage he says they
call it a conspiracy theory they call it
a a great replacement but it's it's the
explicit totally open program of the
Democrat Party to get take take away the
borders and flood the country with
foreigners because it gives them an
electoral advantage that's what he
said and then van Jones he's that here's
that completely unobjectionable
obviously true statement he says and you
know what he's implying here what he's
implying is that the Jews are the most
rotten evil people on Earth and ought to
be rounded up and sent to get camps wait
what when did VI mention the Jews huh
well secretly that's what he was
implying and he's a demagogue and he
good grief man good on him good on him I
if I were vake I wouldn't be offended by
that at all you are not you are not a
serious mainstream conservative until
CNN calls you a Nazi you're not if if
CNN is not calling you a Nazi then you
might as well sign up with the Democrat
Party to to be called an Nazi by the
mainstream left is is the barrier to
entry for a conservative po they start
to call you a Nazi if you if you gently
Advocate that we just cut taxes a little
bit okay the barrier to entry is not
that high and V has passed it so another
the guy's got a lot of achievements in
his life
okay he he's a self-made man he's a
graduate of Yale law school he started a
very successful company he sold it for
something like a billion dollars he is a
bestselling author he is a presidential
candidate who went from no name
recognition to being one of the top guys
in the race and now the top achievement
is the Liars at CNN call him a Nazi good
job right now go to stpaul center.com I
recently had my friend Dr Scott Han on
the show he's the founder of the St Paul
Center which is one of the fastest
growing Catholic organizations in the
world the St Paul Center's mission is to
give you the tools you need to know to
love scripture better to become more
confident in your faith and most
importantly to grow closer to Christ
himself in order to achieve this the St
Paul Center founded a new digital
learning platform called EMAs Academy
EMAs Academy features over 20 video
courses book studies and original series
giving you the ability to learn from
worldclass theologians such as Dr Scott
Han and Dr John bergsma as if you were
right there with them in the classroom I
absolutely love everything and they put
out they're a great place to start your
exploration of your faith there are 12
sessions study by Dr Scott Han is
incredible he traces the meaning of
Holiness from its origins in scripture
to its appearance in our own lives today
this study will help you experience the
transformative power of God's holiness
start learning more about church history
how to interpret the Bible the basics of
Christian prayer and more stpaul
center.com head on over there you can
begin exploring EMAs Academy memberships
are only 25 bucks per month but you can
sign up today for a two-e free trial
right now imagine what could be possible
if we were all to fortify ourselves with
a deeper understanding of scripture and
our faith do not miss this opportunity
to sign up today to begin your journey
with EMAs Academy right now head on over
to hillsdale.edu are you a few years or
decades out of school and wondering what
the heck did I even learn and what was
the point you might even be thinking I
don't have time to learn something new
well if that's you you're not alone and
it's not too late Hillsdale College is
offering more than 40 free online
courses learn about the works of Cs LS
the rise and fall of the Roman Republic
or the history of the ancient Christian
church with Hillsdale College's online
courses if you're not sure where to
start check out CS Lewis on Christianity
in this seven lecture course you will
examine some of Lewis's classic Works
including Mere Christianity the screw
tape letters and the abolition of man
you will also see what lwis had to say
about scripture prayer suffering Joy
Heaven and Hell the course is self-paced
so that you can start whenever and
wherever enroll now in CS Lewis on
Christianity to discover Le is core
lessons on Christianity and how to apply
Faith to your life go to hillsdale.edu
to enroll there's no cost it's easy to
get started hillsdale.edu to enroll
hillsdale.edu
meanwhile the rest of the establishment
not just on the Democrat side but even
on the Republican side of the
establishment they are upset about a
problem that V does not
have part of the knock on V is he's this
young cous guy but the rest of the
political establishment is upset at the
old people who are still in politics Jeb
Bush Jeb Jeb uh just criticized the
disproportionate influence of old people
in politics he said as a 70-year-old
person I am part of the problem it is
time for my generation to get off the
stage politically I hear this a lot
probably a lot of rock ribed
conservatives even are going to agree
with what Jeb says here I do not I do
not suffer from
agism it's very fashionable to say all
these old people they don't know what
they're doing we need to make way for
the UTS hey man I'm a conservative I
don't put that much stock in the UTS
okay I actually think that with age
comes wisdom and sometimes with age
wisdom does not come like in the case of
Joe Biden but sometimes it does and I
don't want to discriminate against old
people in fact the word Senate like the
US Senate comes from the Latin word senx
which means old guy
so I I think it's perfectly fine to have
old guys in politics the problem with
our political order right now is not old
people it's a certain strain of old
thinking that's the problem does anyone
believe that Jeb Bush wants more V
ramaswami in politics V is like 12 years
old he he is not an old man by any means
you think Jeb wants more vies no way I'm
sure I'm sure Jeb hates what VI is
bringing into the Republican party
because what V is bringing to the
Republican party is largely a
repudiation of the Bush family's
contribution to the Republican
Party does does Jeb really hate I don't
know Joe Biden did Jeb really hate that
the Old Guard of does Jeb hate Mitch
McConnell no I don't think
so it's an it's an old line of thinking
that is the problem the proof of this
here is Donald Trump
because even if you hate Donald Trump
you probably don't hate Donald Trump
because of his
age Donald Trump has much more in common
politically with the youngest prominent
figures in the Republican party right
now than he does with the old guys
Donald Trump has much more in common
with
v JD Vance Josh Holly Blake Masters the
the group that is currently called the
new right Trump Trump has much more in
common with them than he does with Mitch
McConnell Joe Biden Nancy Pelosi John
McCain Mitt Romney he's got way more in
common with the young guys that's not
that the big divide is not age the big
divide is ideas there are some
Republicans who want to
maintain
the feckless consensus that predominated
on the right after the Cold War and
throughout the bush administ rtion and
even even into the early Obama
administration and that feckless
consensus was ignore social issues just
focus on projecting American might
abroad and cutting taxes that was the
consensus I mean it was articulated in
fact by George HW Bush just after the
Cold War there was a big debate in the
Republican party it was George HW Bush
versus panan George HW Bush said when we
won the Cold War now we have to win the
peace and we've only got to focus on
expanding in our economic might to the
exclusion basically of every other
question and panan said uhuh we're
fighting a culture War he gave a very
famous speech called the culture War
speech at the 1992 Republican National
Convention and Bush won and Buchanan
lost and the bush view predominated for
26 years and you saw it throughout the
Clinton Administration and the Bush
Administration it was it was the two
were not all that different you saw it
into the early tea party even just focus
on cutting taxes shrinking government
forget the cultural issues the leaders
of the Tea Party especially the the
political leaders of the Tea Party I'm
thinking of Paul Ryan I'm thinking of
the Young Guns so-called in Congress the
the Grassroots of the tea party was was
much more cultural but the the political
leadership at the top focused almost
exclusively on economic issues and it
didn't work okay and then Trump comes
around and he brings back the Buchanan
view is is Jeb Bush really concerned
about age or is he concerned about
something a little bit deeper man what a
great clip that was huh now hey qu
subscribe ring that Bell we'll see you
next time